just passing through
I don't suppose you've got anything rap
is in you can spare do you
yeah looks like these people meet him
one idea
that's very kind of you wasn't expected
word of advice you might want to keep a
low profile tonight golem City can you
sketch him the best of times
this definitely isn't one of them why
what's happened haven't you heard
terrorists try to blow up wauzeka
station and even though people here
couldn't have had anything to do with it
the cops need someone to blame where I
come from cops are supposed to be the
good guys what planet is that because
where I come from the police have a
militarizing for years wasting money and
inciting deep levels of mistrust between
them and the very people they're
supposed to protect is that what's
happening in Gotham City it's happening
all over the place
cops in Gotham are special breed they
control everything here food drugs
neuropathy and not all of them think
very highly of us arms
these cops they're looking for members
of arc all members of our to them one
way or another and some of us may have
even done bad things but not the kind of
things the rest of the world says we've
done sounds like your supporter why
shouldn't the Augmented Rights Coalition
was started with the best of intentions
as a non-violent way to confront in
justices and advance the cause of
Augmented Rights
okay
but in my experience the best of
intentions often go awry that may be
true right now Tallis Rucker and Ark are
the only things keeping people and golem
alive trust me they're the good guys
I'm getting the impression the UCR can
tell us Rucker is some kind of augmented
robin hood's how old you know where I'm
at Alice years ago in India we were both
humanitarian aid volunteers back then do
you good man the press paints him as a
narcissist he has his faults but I
wouldn't believe everything see on
practice moves best occurs at this area
of the complex much heat you know you've
been asking me an awful lot of questions
it's just that I heard Rucker didn't get
augmented momentarily so I'm wondering
how that kind of experience colors a
man's perspective around people dead
callous was almost passionate about the
ability of nuraghe mutations to heal
people's bodies and souls his accident
only strengthened his beliefs
is he still an idealist that after
everything that's happened listen to his
daily broadcasts he believes people will
usually do the right thing in time they
just need to discover what the right
thing is I see thanks for the warning
doc I hope you'll take it to heart
[ __ ]
to us like this